[Music]
the cubicle you've you're really living
in is your story you're gonna go back
into an environment at home where
everybody thinks they know who you are
because you have very carefully created
a cubicle that you show everybody you
are a multi-faceted spiritual creature
that has innumerable facets and faces to
you there is such beauty and complexity
in you and yet you choose to show four
faces of a cubicle and you have created
that story of your life and who you are
through training and I would say it's
the biggest problem then all of us face
in this room is the story that you now
tell yourself with what your life has
been it's keeping you in a box
that's the great Zack Bush back for
round number three and this is the
ritual podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast how are you guys
doing what's happening my name is rich
roll
I am your podcast host this is my show
welcome or welcome back quick reminder
I'm doing my first live show live
podcast extravaganza with special guests
to be announced it's all going down
Friday September 27th mark your calendar
at the historic the gorgeous 1100 seat
Wilshire Ebell theatre right here in Los
Angeles super super excited about how
this is shaping up cannot wait for this
evening for more information and tickets
they're going fast
click the appearances tab on my website
retro comm and grab them while they're
hot second I implore anyone listening
who is struggling with their diet to
check out our plant power meal planner
super affordably priced at just a dollar
90 a week the price of a cup of coffee
you get access to thousands essentially
an unlimited supply of nutritious and
delicious plant-based recipes grocery
lists grocery delivery and access to a
team of experienced dietary coaches
seven days a week to learn more and sign
up visit meals rich roll calm ok he's
back people today the man himself one of
the most fascinating the most popular
guest by a longshot to grace this
platform Zack Bush MD returns for round
3 of the podcast and I gotta say this
one is a mind-blower
for those newer to the show Zack is many
things he is the founder and director of
M clinic integrative health center in
Virginia and I know he hates when people
say this but it is true he is one of the
few triple board-certified physicians in
America with expertise and internal
medicine endocrinology and metabolism
and hospice palliative care in addition
to his work in functional medicine
longevity autism gut health cancer the
list goes on and on he is an avid
environmentalist and activist involved
in a multitude of projects that focus on
everything from ecology soil health
regenerative agriculture farmer
well-being and spirituality along those
lines I implore all of you to check out
his documentary series it's called
farmers footprint and it takes a look at
the impact of glyphosate on human and
environmental health which is something
we talked about in our previous episodes
and it's done through the lens of
farmers and their communities you can
view that on Zach's website Zach Bush MD
comm or at farmers footprint dot us and
I'll put links to those sites in the
show notes I've said it before but I
think it's worth repeating in my opinion
zach is a master healer he is a master
consciousness a gift to humanity and
somebody I'm very proud to call friend
after Zach's previous appearances on the
show episodes 353 which was back in
March of 2018 and episode 414 from
January of this year to the most
impactful and and moving conversations
of my life we invited Zach and his wife
Jen Perl Bush to join us on our recent
retreat in Italy so today's conversation
which I think you'll find goes in
directions quite different from our
previous conversations is a product of
that experience and it's all coming up
after these messages of support from the
sponsors that make this show possible
the first of which is from my friends at
prints on wood it's summer which means
weddings birthdays anniversaries what
else family reunions all that kind of
stuff right and it's really hard to find
a cool unique memorable and meaningful
gift which is why prints on wood is so
freakin cool because a beautiful photo
printed directly onto a gorgeous piece
of wood that's a pretty dang hard thing
to beat several months ago out of the
blue I might add these guys have prints
on wood sent Julie and I some photos of
our family and we absolutely love them
the prints are a total work of art each
one comes ready to hang right
the box we have them displayed
throughout our hallway and whenever
guests come over someone always comments
on how gorgeous and unique they are
prints on wood are great for more than
just gifts they're a meaningful way for
you to document your own journey like
that epic marathon finish or completing
an Ironman or your beautiful Big Sur
bike ride with friends I mean what's the
point of taking all of these amazing
photos if they just live on your phone
and you never display or share them not
only are their products impressive
prints on wood also has a business ethos
that I really resonate with there are
family owned they're husband and wife
team Derek and Aaron Swynford founded
over 19 years ago and all their products
are made right here in California in a
factory that is 100% solar-powered all
the wood is sustainably sourced and it
shipped to you in recyclable packaging
which is amazing but their environmental
stewardship goes far beyond just
manufacturing practices prints on wood
partnered with farmers footprint sacks
organization that I just mentioned
you're gonna learn more about Zak today
of course and they donate one dollar
from every print order to that very
important organization because they want
to be part of the regenerative
agricultural movement that helps farmers
rebuild organic matter and living
biodiversity in the soil which I don't
know if there's anything cooler than
that and what makes this really
over-the-top special for me is that
Derek and Aaron actually joined us in
Italy for our retreat so not only do
they support Zach and farmers footprint
they were physically present for the
conversation that you're about to hear
so the next time you're looking for a
unique super cool meaningful and
environmentally sustainable gift that
gives back I mean what else checks all
those boxes check out prints on wood
right now my listeners can receive an
incredible 30 percent off their first
order from prints on wood when you go to
prints on wood calm and enter the code
rich roll that check out that's prints
on wood calm code rich roll at checkout
to get 30% off your first
today's episode is also brought to you
by design crowd while we're on the topic
of beautiful visual designs
how old is your business logo does your
website need a graphic makeover
if so design crowd can really help sort
you out think of design crowd like this
digital hub that connects entrepreneurs
startups small businesses solopreneurs
with designers from around the world so
whether you want a new business card and
infographic or perhaps a custom landing
page design crowd has over 550,000
creatives ready to help you out with
awesome designs so how does it work well
first you visit design crowd comm you
post a brief description of what you
need and design crowd will then invite
its creatives to respond and within a
few hours you'll receive your first
design and over the course of the next
three to ten days you'll receive 60 to
100 different designs you then get to
pick your favorite one and approve
payment to the designer super simple
right
design crowd even offers 24/7 customer
support in the US UK Australia and
Canada along with a satisfaction
guarantee that includes unlimited
revision requests so you're always going
to find exactly what you're looking for
so whether you're a band that needs new
killer posters or a local bike shop
looking for fresh signage let design
crowd support your success design crowd
is even offering listeners of this show
up to $100 off their first design
project go to design crowd comm four
slash rich roll that's des AG n CR o WD
comm four slash rich roll or simply
enter the discount code rich roll when
posting a project on design crowd and
finally we're brought to you by
Squarespace the simplest way for anyone
to build a beautiful landing page
website or online store now that you've
dialed in that logo it's time to craft a
website that looks just as good as the
work that you create so whether you're a
business owner needing a new compelling
website and artist wanting to show off
your portfolio Squarespace has you
covered with a huge catalogue of
industry specific designer templates you
can rely on a
with shiny features that make it easy
and dare I say fun to customize a page
with Squarespace you can design a
stunning website in a matter of hours
they're straightforward interface is
clean it's easy to navigate and super
simple is setup and the best part is
that anyone can use Squarespace to
create a professional website from
scratch regardless of skill level you
don't need to know a single line of code
sites look professionally designed
regardless of your skill level no design
mastery required so make the most
squarespace's visual designs and get a
free domain when you sign up for a year
right now my listeners can get 10% off
their first purchase with Squarespace
all you got to do is go to Squarespace
calm for such rich role and use the
offer code rich roll to get 10% off your
first purchase
that's squarespace.com rich roll and
don't forget to enter the code rich roll
out make your next move with a stunning
website from Squarespace okay Zach Zach
Busch MD so on previous episodes we
explored everything from the impact of
glyphosate on degenerative disease to
the importance of regenerative
agriculture to what can be done to heal
ourselves and the planet we share and
expanding upon those conversations today
we go in a few new in different
directions we talk about our
relationship with pain both physical and
psychic we talk about our unhealthy
obsession with the pursuit of comfort
the stories we craft that form our
identity and and more often than not
hold us hostage and many other subjects
including some shared experiences from a
group holotropic breathing experience
that Julie had taken the group through
prior to the session which I think you
guys are going to find fascinating
like the recent Jemma Newman episode
this was recorded live from our event in
Italy thus audio-only no youtube version
of this and it closes with Zach leading
this amazing meditation and I should say
that we edited out or truncated some of
the
long pregnant pauses or extended moments
of silence during that meditation simply
for the sake of you guys the listeners
as a final note I wanted to add that our
retreat errs the people that attended
our Italy experience on their own accord
have collectively raised and donated 81
thousand dollars for Zach's farmers
footprint organization and docu-series
which is just incredible so immense
gratitude thank you to all who attended
and contributed if Zach's message moves
you to get involved you can learn more
and donate yourself at farmers footprint
dot us okay this is a deep one again
perhaps a little bit different from that
which you've come to expect from dr.
Zach but I think something tells me
you're gonna dig it I certainly did so
let's get into it this is me and dr.
Zach Bush
I fall in love with all you this week
he's been awesome it's so beautiful
every single one of you that I've had
time to sit and talk with just blow my
mind you're just beautiful talented
extraordinary human beings that all
walked into this week ready to [ __ ]
change everything and that's unusual and
I'm amazed by that I'm just amazed as I
was just talking rich as we were sitting
here beforehand of like I have talked to
people all over the world and all this
but it's unusual to come into an
environment where for 40-plus people are
here to change everything that it takes
to be a better you and it's really an
honor to be here and I just have
extraordinary gratitude to Julianne rich
for including Jen and I in this week
it's a powerful opportunity for us to be
human to show who we are and be
vulnerable as well as learn from the
depth that's in this room the things
that you guys experienced during your
breathing the holotropic breathing is
humbling to be witnessed that not enough
humans get to see other humans become
Buffalo
that's freaking unique and it's
beautiful and I pulled the whale card
and that was an interesting journey just
in reading that that card and so these
animals are one of my deepest passions
as the animals on earth and the
devastating effects we've had on them in
the last few decades is almost
unspeakable and I'm just so grateful
that we can embody that and become
perhaps part of a higher consciousness
where these animals are not only
respected on earth but they become part
of us and we become part of them and you
guys have embodied that really well this
is some of you more than others well I
think we can all agree that we're very
blessed to have you and Jen in our
presence it's been a gift to just have
you here and to kind of make today Zach
Busch Day how many of you here heard one
of the two podcast episodes that that
Zach and I did together yeah almost
everybody it's it's a it's a joke in our
house the regularity with which I get
feedback like just months and months you
know after like I think yesterday
somebody you know sent a message about
it so it's crazy how much your message
has connected with this audience and
it's really cool man so I want to
continue that conversation what was
interesting about what you just said
about pulling the whale card I don't
know if you know this but like two days
ago a giant well I think was a sperm
whale washed on shore in Italy in Italy
and they discovered about 88 pounds of
plastic and it's good and I think that
kind of perfectly in capture you know
it's like it's interesting that you
pulled the whale card you know with that
because it speaks to so much of what
you're about wow that's a little
overwhelming yeah well
yeah that's very pertinent to it and we
would like to talk about hey thanks
though well we let when we last left off
the second podcast that we did kind of
ended with this epic monologue that you
blessed all of us with which really kind
of pivoted on this theme of the cycles
of life and rethinking you know what
death means and how that impacts how we
live our lives and I thought maybe you
could expound a little bit on that since
it was so impactful for so many people
yeah
and that's that monologue came from you
really I mean I do want to point that
out that much like the energy that you
guys have accomplished this week what
you guys have accomplished in yourself
transformations as we have come out of
the space that that rich and Julie have
chosen to hold for all of us to be
transformative in and that's why your
podcast has become a worldwide bests is
because you holding extraordinary spaces
for people to to find things in
themselves that they didn't know was
ready to be spoken and so you gave me an
avenue and by the time somebody sits
with you for 90 minutes they don't know
how they got to where they're at that's
for sure and so that was a real you know
a tribute to what you do really more
than myself but that that moment I think
is worth as a wonderful starting point
is the monologue was based on my
experience in the ICU of watching
patients die and then be resuscitated
and give report as to what they just
experienced and that came around to this
single line which was that what they
experienced the very first thing they
said in their experience wasn't about I
saw the white light or I saw Jesus or I
saw this or that Minaya accepted for the
first time in my life and in all of the
sessions that I've been in individually
with many of you this week this becomes
a theme for each of us as we don't feel
seen we feel no matter how much we do or
produce we feel unseen and therefore
unrecognized and therefore unaccepted
and we go through all kinds of
ridiculous social machinations to try to
reconnect and to get some sort of
affirmation from each other that we are
seeing or respected or loved and it's
ethereal and it's a chasing after the
wind because ultimately the human mind
is no more capable of seeing you each
for who you are than it is figuring
anything out and the human mind is a
very weak agent of conception and very
weak agent of analysis because it works
in such a black and white physical plane
when in fact you know much of I think
many people that you work with on your
podcast rich are coming to that podcast
out of having reached flow state somehow
and so our athletes are phenomenal at
demonstrating what flow state looks like
and that's what you I'm sure got into in
you're chasing ultra there is that
you're you moved from a state of
disconnect I suspect and at forty nine
or whenever it was that you were in that
moment of crisis and that transformation
I guess I'd turn it back on you for a
moment and just ask what if in the lens
of a my scene where were you add when as
a lawyer and in that and not necessarily
just seen by the world but seen by
yourself like what aspects of yourself
could you see clearly at that point in
your life and woman what was hidden yeah
it's a great question I mean certainly I
didn't feel that I was being seen I was
unable to truly see myself other than
glimpses of the possibility of what I
knew you know I could be I guess but
without giving myself permission to
inhabit that you know so I felt strongly
that I was living the wrong life I
didn't have clarity on what the correct
life for me would be and I definitely
had a powerful sense of
not only being not seen but not being
able to see myself and I had to you know
create painful moments for myself and or
to compel me to confront certain things
about how I was living in order to you
know force me to work through it in
hindsight do you think there was parts
of you could see some clearly that could
see clearly could see clearly of
yourself was there parts of your
character sigh yeah but I think it was
clouded by fear you know oh interesting
which made it murky it was too scary to
really look at that but you know Julie
was incredibly helpful as a support
system in helping me you know have the
courage in the fortitude to be able to
not only begin to expand that aperture
but do the work required to walk towards
it I think that is one of the most
profound statements that we can all hear
is that even the parts of us that we can
see clearly are clouded by fear which is
so true I think we are so afraid of
ourselves which is so bizarre that we've
been set in fear of ourselves and you
know it brings I can't remember who the
famous quotes were that have been around
this subject but you know you you hear
the the the theme of the thing that you
should fear the most is your own power
you know because you're not connecting
to it and that's the fearful part is
what are you doing
disconnected from your power and do you
have a sense where that fear was coming
from what was the origin of fear and all
that or was it too vague to even
pinpoint yeah that's a great question I
don't know that I can identify the locus
of that other than to say that perhaps
it had something to do with with the
power being located in a place that was
so far askance of my sense of what was
socially acceptable for somebody who had
had my experience
that the fear had to do with stepping
outside of what I knew even as
dysfunctional as it was to try something
completely outside of my comfort zone on
an experience
that's spot on and I think we can all
relate to that in different ways and
that it's we would rather stay
uncomfortable in the knowing miss then
jump into the unknown yeah there's a
there's a sort of common refrain in
recovery circles which goes something
along the lines of when the pain of your
current situation exceeds the fear of
the unknown and that's when you change
right so that's that thing where we're
you know the pain that you create for
yourself can actually be the catalyst
for the change that you seek not that
pain is necessary for that
transformation but it can be a useful
mechanism for it and so it's not always
to be avoided but rather to be
understood and leveraged and I think the
pain is perhaps necessary on some level
for change and transformation and this
is what I get terrified as a physician
of and I saw it in spades in the hospice
world which is our dependence and
overuse of art narcotics and so the
opiate and you know stuff and everything
else that we're we're on this opiate
explosion is dulling pain yeah it's a
barrier to confronting the pain that can
be that transformative vehicle and what
if we did that at the end of life to
everybody so you couldn't make your
ultimate transformation and that
terrifies me about our current hospice
movement which is based on pain control
what a ludicrous goal ultimately for a
species to Dahl the the exquisitely
developed sensory processing that would
suggest pain and is interesting that we
can have a sensory experience of pain
from emotional stress yeah it doesn't
have to be biologic whatsoever and the
Chinese in their 4,000 years of wisdom
and the medicine
there I've done a very good job of
showing us where pain shows up
biologically as always has a an
emotional spiritual underpinning so to
play devil's advocate a little bit as
compassionate beings we don't want to
see the people that we love suffering
and if somebody is in that place nearing
the end of their life what is the you
know appropriate compassionate response
that doesn't involve overly medicating
it's pretty beautiful that's a great
question obviously and critical and the
answer is touch and human touch is has
an extremely powerful way to reduce pain
and in the same rate at which we've
started to overuse narcotics and and and
the whole addiction you know process
here we've stopped touching our patients
and we've stopped touching our loved
ones who are dying somewhat out of just
an untrained of what that touching looks
like from family members Cormac
McCarthy's one of my favorite authors
out there in modern writers out there
and he's so brutal with his simple
descriptions of a scene and he loves the
topic of brutal death and pain and you
know horrific scenes that he paints and
his most benign book got got the most
accolades which was the all the pretty
horses but blood meridian is worth a
read an incredible book that one just
like is brutal in its depiction of human
violence and what you see depict it off
and and and even I think the beginning
of all the pretty horses is this stark
scene of somebody just died and they're
their coffin is in the home for days and
that was normal back then you know you
know just even at the beginning of the
nineteen 1900s it was death happened in
the home and the family was intimately
involved with that
there was a process of picking up the
body and wrapping it up and you know it
wasn't a sterile process there was
nobody that came swooping in to rush
that off to the corner and you know all
of this and so there was an experience
with death and not just on the human
plane which you also see in Cormac
McCarthy's work is the brutal you know
death that was happening around them on
the farm you know there's horses dying
you know animals you know falling into
traumatic end points and and death on
all kinds of levels we were intimately
involved with that for all of history
and perhaps most of all in war and one
of the things that terrifies me right
now is that we haven't as Americans been
immersed in war in a long time and
that's it let's just pause on that for a
minute because that's a that's a gnarly
thing to say right I think it is
normally I think I'm afraid that that
history repeats itself when we don't pay
attention to history and I'm not the
only person afraid of that obviously
it's been said by a lot smarter people
than me but if we look at World War two
as an obvious house spring of World War
one which was an obvious house springing
of some of the wars that were happening
in Europe at the end of the 1800s we
start to see that there was again a
familiarity with brutal brutal violence
with war on their soils as Americans we
just can't even fathom World War one
we lost 60,000 some soldiers and world
in Vietnam over a 25 year period and so
if you imagine that and then to keep in
mind that that had to be done at nearly
face-to-face levels of combat where men
were within 10 to 30 yards and cutting
each other up with machine-gun fire
razor wire explosives literally body
parts raining down on each other and
being covered in each other's blood and
feces and living in each other species
and the trench warfare that
on four years in the same trenches you
all have not experienced pain you have
an experience suffering you have an
experience to the extremity of what the
human mindset and body is capable of
receiving and witnessing and
perpetrating yeah to you know say one
thing about what you just said there are
interesting parallels between warfare
and this relationship with death that we
have in the sense that what was once
tactile and personal in the Cormac
McCarthy sense has become white washed
and sanitized so warfare is no longer
you know hand-to-hand combat in the
trench like World War one it's you know
rose it's a shot from a drone or it's
cyber warfare from 3,000 miles away that
moves you know economies and impacts
lives a little bit more indirectly and
death has been removed from our visual
and emotional field and put behind
closed walls because we're so afraid to
look at it because it would force us to
look at ourselves so what do we take
from this shift in how we manage these
two things in terms of how to inform how
to live our lives better that's thank
you for really knowing I'm gonna take it
back to that war just for a second just
so we can loop that back so I want I
want you to realize that those men after
two million people dead we're still
marching into that warfare knowing
exactly what they were and that they
were gonna die and they wrote some of
the most heart-rending stories are
letters back to their loved ones you
know in preparation for their death and
yet at no point was there fear in there
and so how is it that a hundred years
later were sitting here and what we're
afraid of is ourselves we're afraid as
two men sitting on a couch together the
our highest fear is that we don't know
ourselves and that we don't know why
we're here and that we might not be
doing enough and that we don't really
know how to connect to the people that
we love and
[Music]
where and where did we how do we get
there you know it's the point where we
didn't we we lost the the fear of death
historically we could we could divorce
from that and then we lose the
experience of real pain through this
pursuit of a comfort lifestyle
ultimately which has been this you know
hundreds of year march towards that but
obviously in the last 50 years there's
never been a faster march towards such a
massive portion of humanity living in
comfort you know only to experience
higher pain and it's interesting that
our chronic pain rates accelerate as our
lifestyles appear to get more
comfortable yeah that's the great irony
right that that that comfort and luxury
is actually creating the pain that we
then need to medicate ourselves against
and so that's where I think we have to
reevaluate our concept of pain is pain
actually a bad thing is it something
that we need to avoid and I would argue
that not at all because in an endocrine
system so as an endocrinologist where
it's my favorite field of medicine and
that's why I went into it in the sense
that everything is a feedback loop and
so if you have if you eat and sugar your
insulin goes up if your insulin goes up
glucose goes into the cell when your
blood sugar drops insulin goes back down
and so there's a feedback loop that
achieves all of that there's this
constant communication so parathyroid
hormone goes up to release calcium from
the bone and then it drops down to get
calcium back into the bone and so you
have this constant regenerative cycling
of tissue of genes of proteins of all of
the mechanics of cellular health are
always in transition they're always in
this given exchange there's push and
pull give and take kind of communication
and our whole neurologic systems are
loaded with pain receptors and we have
this very natural mechanism that
releases opioids from our own cells
and we call them endorphins and we call
them a lot of different little molecular
terms but these little molecules all
have relationship
to morphine the structure of morphine is
very similar to endorphin itself and
those endorphins that you achieve when
you're running are hitting all of those
pain receptors and so it's very likely
that you wake up with more back pain and
then you will have an hour into running
and so you'll hit that threshold where
the first and half hours is misery when
you're trying to get moving and then
suddenly you hit that threshold where
the pain just goes away I'd be curious
eating to when you were running all
those those ultra marathons and and
Hawaii what was that journey like I mean
you did it over and over again to
yourself like there must have been so
much pain that week yeah but it's a it's
a different I mean there are different
kinds of pain - you know psychic pain
emotional pain you know the physical
pain and then within the physical is it
acute or is it you know McHale abrade I
sucked it so I don't know I don't know
like I don't know how to answer that
other than to say a - your first point
yeah like I have some like back stuff
now and I'm a little creaky at 52 and I
get out of bed in the morning I'm like
I'm not moving so fluidly but yeah half
an hour into the run that's like all the
pain goes away you know basically that's
the best that I feel like you know all
day when that's happening and I think
you know one's relationship to pain is
similar to one's relationship to time in
that it's malleable and flexible
depending upon your experience right so
your exposure to it allows you to
acclimate to it and develop a new and
different relationship to it that that
in my experience allows you to kind of
overcome the fear around it like once
you embrace it rather than run away from
it you realize that it can be this this
crucible for for growth and progress and
by progress I mean personal growth
things of that nature
which would you rather have you just
letting out a bunch of different types
of pain which would I rather have
physical but common psychological pain
well I mean you know physical pain is is
very like binary you know I think there
was some study I stumbled across some
article about a study
that's that you know the psychic and
emotional pain that we have is you know
is is we underestimate it it's actually
just as as impactful and profound as the
physical pain but we don't think about
the those two things in the same way nor
do we treat them in the same way so I
would I think you're exactly right and
in in my personal experience but
definitely my experience as a physician
I see the psychic pain having farm
longer ramifications and more
detrimental ramifications to function
than physical pain physical pain is
actually a neurologic experience where
you have a neuron that's sensing a
stimulus and it's sending a signal to
your brain this is gonna that's then
gonna send the experience of pain to
your your sensory you know processing
center whereas emotional pain is so
vague you know psychic pain is so vague
and it's trigger that your body can't
prepare the same way you don't have the
same warning systems you don't have the
same coping mechanisms and so it's this
insidious thing that creeps in and
suddenly you're in you had an incredible
term the other day I think was the
crucible of suffering and we can find
ourselves in these moments of for you it
was a couple nights miss sleep and you
find yourself in the crucible suffering
yeah we've all missed those nights of
sleep and we all sensed that it's so
interesting how vulnerable the human
brain is right like we are all on the
brink of insanity you missed three
nights of sleep and you get a little
alcohol on top of that and you have a
little bit of you know emotional
stressor that you don't understand where
it came from and all that and pretty
soon you're you're pretty much psychotic
that's the reassuring part of being and
so just just know you're not alone in
that that's I guess where I meet you
there we are so vulnerable and I see
this most and you know in my journey
with my psych patients this woman that
has been with me the longest now have
been her doctor for almost 20 years and
she came to me she was on 35 medications
and 16 of those were essentially acting
drugs
her brain yeah mood mood stabilizers
anti-spasmodics you know she was on
every freaking drug class that we have
and usually two again and for most of
those two or three from a single drug
class and so she had so much redundancy
in her drugs and she spent you know from
age like 16 on to about you know when I
met her she was about 46 so she spent
you know 30 years in psych wards in and
out of Psych hospitals and lived more
time in psych wards than she did outside
of them and then was in you know yeah
section 8 housing and all this kind of
you know disability and all that between
that was 2002 that I picked her up I
guess so game 2002 and by 2012 10 years
later I had her down to two medications
and she hadn't been in the psych ward in
two and a half years over the last eight
years she's popped into psych wards
twice but there's only because she was
homeless in those moments and she knew
how she could work the system to to get
a get a bed under her and so she
basically faked neuroses and got herself
into psych wards twice since then and
she's not psychotic she's not a
psychotic person but on those psych
wards she she was a terror like she's a
relatively short woman but you know
quite overweight from all the drugs that
she'd been on all of them were causing
obesity shutting down her metabolism but
she had been famous for blowing through
armored doors she could she could run
herself through armored doors and psych
units and so she had this like
preternatural strength in her psychosis
that she could she was scary violent
she's one of the most gentle people I
know and she's one of the most intuitive
people and I call her my Oracle now
because she'll call me up you know it
would be like dr. Porsche something is
about to happen to you next week that's
gonna be really interesting and great in
this way and sure enough next week
something happens she's very tied into
the spiritual realm she can see things
that we can't see and so when she
becomes vulnerable when she becomes
weakened she looks floridly psychotic in
a different way than you and I would
because she's closer to this veil and
that we
really that is harder to approach for
for people with more biologic faculties
in place perhaps and so I point to her
as an example of this this threshold of
is pain good as pain bad because
basically she was on 32 drugs to dull
her experience of depression and anxiety
to just a fog and she was kept in a fog
for 30 years and suffered despite all of
the fog and in the end she just wanted
to be seen and so what I ended up you
know being able to do as a human being
was just really listened to her story
over and over again and she had to tell
it to me until I was so tired of hearing
her story and it took me a long time to
find out that her story ultimately was
her biggest problem that and I would say
it's the biggest problem that all of us
face in this room is the story that you
now tell yourself of what your life has
been it's keeping you in a box so her
story is obvious to look at and while
her box was she's a psych patient and
she is there once I had listened to her
story enough times as to how she got
herself there by 16 into psychosis turns
out in that situation it was her she her
father runs a service station over in
the Stan area and in the beautiful
chandelier Virginia and by the time she
was 12 years old he he was hat allowing
his employees to give him some money so
that they could rape his daughter behind
the service station and this happened
for you know a decade of her life and in
and out of psych ward she should come
back and be raped again and her father
was perpetrating you know this situation
around her and so you hear that story
and you're like well that's horrific and
that's you know what psyche could
possibly handle that and the answer is
she could have handled it because she
does now she handles that story without
any drugs because it got hurt and she
was able to process that enough times
and realize that it wasn't her she was
much bigger entity
than that story for a moment in this
biologic body she had been raped many
times
her father was somebody she could not
trust but she's much bigger than that
she's a spiritual being and she got to
this largely through her own you know
kind of Christian mindset faith and you
know some interesting people came into
her life to kind of I think you know
infuse this with you know her knowledge
of finding that bigger self but she now
sees herself as this this energetic
entity this this woman and the bigger
sense of the word she's a nurturing
creative force on the planet that can is
tied into all of the history of God and
spirituality and humanity and it's as as
long as she can stay grounded in that
then the the short traumas that happened
in her life here don't don't hurt her
it doesn't cause pain yeah I mean what
it that's an amazing story I mean what I
hear and that is is just the tremendous
resilience that that we all have and
that we're born you know capable and we
have everything that we need to not only
survive but you know whether whatever
life throws at us but we're we've
developed an insulated culture in which
we dis empower people by treating them
as if they're powerless or incapable of
handling these certain things and it's
delicate because you want to give people
the support that they need to deal with
something as traumatic as that I mean I
can't possibly imagine but to say to
somebody like okay this is this is like
you need to be on all these pills or you
need this and that is to tell somebody
that they are not capable and it's to
strip them of their power right and so
what is the long-term implication of
that message that you're sending to
people and to what extent is this
epidemic of people desiring to be seen
and not being seen being driven by
loneliness and like what Johann Hari
would call lost connections like we're
just despite you know the internet
connecting us all we've never been more
separated from each other and
and more alone like we're not living you
know like this week has been on some
level an experiment in in alternative
communal living and it feels good I
think everybody here would say like we
all feel so connected to each other and
there's a life force and a vitality that
comes with that that we don't get to
experience in our daily lives when we go
back and we all immerse ourselves in our
various you know forms of cubicles in
which we all live right so how can we
restructure this to create you know to
recapture those connections to see each
other to allow ourselves to be seen and
communally to support each other so that
we can feel empowered and be empowered
and provide empowerment to others so how
can we solve all the problems yeah yeah
that's that's super good I I love those
questions it's like okay succinctly
let's yeah in some ways I think that the
fastest way to get there is let go of
your story the reason why you guys have
had such a transformational events this
week is because nobody here really knew
your story and there wasn't time for us
to all learn each other's stories
instead we chose to meet each other
right where each of us without without
any preconceived notions of who you all
are or what faculties or experiences or
accomplishments you've had and just say
I'm human sweet I am too like let's like
just do this thing let's just start
breathing and see where this goes and
suddenly people are turning into other
animals and and you feel vulnerable
enough to share that and you express you
know the horrific things that's happened
in your life that would have you know
led to being an animal and embodying
that experience and so how can we do
that how can we create a society where
we don't fall back into our cubicles the
cubicle you've you're really living in
is your story you're gonna go back into
an environment at home where everybody
thinks they know who you are because you
have very carefully created a cubicle
that you show everybody and you want
them you get frustrated when they can't
see all four sides of your cubicle be
like what you don't even know me
like you are a multiple multifaceted
spiritual creature that has innumerable
facets and faces to you there is such
beauty and complexity in you and yet you
choose to show four faces of a cubicle
and you have created that story of your
life and who you are through training we
do this with Seavey's and you know the
curriculum vitae and the resume and all
this stuff like we build this long story
of what we've done in our life isn't it
ridiculous that I could look at a resume
and then suppose that I know anything
about this human being that's applying
for a job isn't that ridiculous that you
would actually put something up on a
dating website that you would think
would show some face of who you are
isn't it ridiculous that your partner in
life who knows you better than emails
can't see you because you won't let them
that's weird what are we doing what
we're doing is acting out of fear we're
afraid to let down those four walls
because we're afraid there's nothing
inside or perhaps we're afraid that that
what would be discovered inside what is
tantamount to being unlovable yes and if
there was something inside we would have
to be lovable right and so I think it's
this sense of hollowness yeah and so is
it possible that you're unlovable and
for me I had to you know face this very
brutally and my you know well compared
to World War one not at all brutally
but again sometimes that psychic pain
can be greater than them any physical
threat had a great marriage I thought I
was married for 18 years together 20
years I met this woman when I was pretty
young and had two amazing kids and never
really had a fight in 20 years no
conflict in the marriage but we the
adversity that we dealt with as a couple
was really around extended family so her
whole family including herself were
suffered from major depression over
their lifetimes many many times and a
couple of her siblings tried to commit
suicide one of them and protect them
many many times so we rehabbed our
siblings in our home for years at a time
and so those were the challenges that
came up in those and so from my rational
brain I was like I've got a great
marriage it's amazing like no conflict
we can support other people you know all
this and but there was this huge
loneliness developing in both of our
lives because we were showing each other
we were building stories we were
building these complicated long stories
of who we were becoming and we we could
know each other less and less over time
and I did that to myself I created a
story that was so complicated and I had
to do with being a doctor ultimately and
yes she knew me before I was a doctor
and watch me through that journey and
you know a whole stupid thing that
everybody ever always write introduces
me as this you know parts of my story
which is going triple what certain I
hear that so many times I'm like if I
ever hear a triple board-certified you
know I'm gonna kill somebody like I just
so sick of hearing that that sentence
and I've asked my employees to stop
sending out that bio just like say just
Zak he's kind of a confused guy he's
here to talk to you you know just like
send out something that's a little
closer to mark you know yeah
just like lost he's just like wandering
around you just ran into you know he
couldn't find an end point so he's still
wandering is something more realistic
you know then then making it sound like
a bunch of achievements and and so I
built all these stories this long story
and I was looking for self-worth in
pouring out service and being an
ultimate service machine and I was
pretty friggin good at it and at the
cost of complete alienation from my wife
and she didn't there's no way she could
have known me by the end of that 20-year
journey and she had respect for me and
she wasn't angry at me but she was like
it was nothing to touch and that you
know that was a number of years ago now
obviously and the result that my life
was largely that I couldn't touch
anybody either
and so I had become untouchable because
of the complexity of my story and I
couldn't touch anybody because of the
complexity of my story I was so walled
off in my cubicle of my story and you
mentioned you know this identity of
resilience in this woman like you know
what a resilient
personality must have survived that and
I've come to see that that identity of
resilience be the most destructive self
identity that somebody can have because
if your self identity becomes I am
resilient what you need to prove that
your identity you need difficulty you
need pain suffering difficulty trauma so
that you can be resilient again you will
keep creating trauma in your life if
your identity is resilience you will
never become successful if your identity
is resilience because you would have to
lose your self identity to find ease and
success another one that I see all the
time is the idea of Mia fix it and I
think that's where I fall into I can fix
anything
and
say the Savior I'm I can literally fix
anything if you have a flat tire no
problem I worked for a tire company
he'll fix your tire refrigerators down
no problem I can fix your refrigerator
the car goes out no problem I did the
car mechanics for years I didn't go fix
your alternator no problem you need a
house built no problem I have a general
contractor's license I'll build you a
house you know yeah I am a freaking
pathetic fixer like to the nth degree
fixer and if your identity is a fixer
what do you need in your life everyday
broken broken you need a lot of [ __ ]
broken and if there's nothing broken
you'll probably fly off the handle and
break something yeah are you going to an
existential crisis now you're an
identity crisis like I'm useless to the
world [ __ ] useless I haven't done
anything in a day I haven't fixed the
damn thing today and so this is how our
story becomes an identity that's usually
can be boiled down to one word and each
of you that I've met with this week have
a one word identity that we can find
pretty quickly and be like do you really
want to be that no I hate that I hate
[ __ ] fixing things every day and in
fact that's what I [ __ ] at most of all
isn't my only learn a wonderful wife
everybody wants me to fix [ __ ] I know
you want to fix [ __ ] you're like don't
put you're projecting yourself on other
people like other people don't they just
they just mentioned something and you
suddenly make that into something you
need to go fix they were just reporting
status that they weren't telling you it
wasn't a to-do list they were they were
activating so how do we transcend these
one word identity constructs that we
create for ourselves it's it's the
hardest thing we can do and and yet it
is done instantaneously it's a decision
that can be had which says are you
willing to let go of everything you
think you are are you willing to
actually become nothing for a moment
this is where where pain can be powerful
because short of pain who's gonna say
yes to that exactly exactly and nowhere
more definitely do we need that at the
end of life probably you know if we
haven't found self yet we need to find
it in those last couple minutes of life
so that we can have closure on this
biologic journey that we did in this
body and have a rise in consciousness
and I get increasingly excited about our
clinic because we do you know biology
anymore and it frustrates the hell out a
lot of my people are coming in clinic
the first time a patient comes in with
cancer and they know that I've got an
outside box purge cancer and all this
and they want me to freaking fix their
cancer and we will never talk about
their cancer and they keep trying to
bring it back together and we talk about
something else because the cancer is not
the problem the cancer is a symptom
downstream of this disconnect ultimately
from themselves and the psychic trauma
that's been held in their body from not
being themselves has created massive
disconnect at the physiology level and
there's profound loneliness happening
down at the cellular level to achieve a
cancer cell I can't remember if we've
talked about this before or not but but
a cancer cell is has been sliced off
from all communication and once it loses
communication with from the greater
organism it it hasn't lost one thing
which is a drive for life and so it's
very fascinating that at the cell level
one of your skin cells has a driver for
life one skin cell independently with
nothing else around it still has a drive
for life it's gonna try to make
something bigger than itself
and so it becomes poorly differentiated
meaning that it doesn't make skin
anymore instead it makes what we would
call a tumor it's creating a pluripotent
or more multi-dimensional cell and it
starts to proliferate because it can't
repair itself the hallmark of a cancer
cell is a lonely cell that can't repair
itself and so it's only choice in its
highest state of damages to proliferate
but what's fascinating about that is
that the malignancy is triggered by the
disconnection
from the community and the network right
and this is something that that operates
at the micro level but is also you know
ultimately very true at the at the most
macro level of how we live I mean we can
think of that guy who climbed up the you
know the hotel there to shoot all those
people in Las Vegas right it's like he's
like he is a cancer dancer so who is
activated in a malignant way through
disconnection and he's out to try to
find self-identity through destruction
of the environment and I think that's
why we create war
I think nations go to war trying to find
self-identity because they've lost their
core and so they go kill other things to
try to find some relevance or some sense
of power because they lost it and this
is what terrifies me that we haven't had
a war on our soil in over a hundred
years with a civil war being our last
major one is that we're gonna do that
again to find ourselves yeah well one of
the things that's that's interesting
about your work is is that the path
forward involves creating connection but
even more so it's about discovering the
connection that's already there like in
this this idea of the the quorum sensing
that you're talking about like we are
already more connected than we're
consciously aware of and developing a
means of kind of understanding on an
intuitive and unconscious as well as
conscious level the connection that we
all share is a way of overriding that
sense of disconnection that is creating
all of these problems it's perfect
transition yeah so quorum sensing is a
description of a hyper intelligence in
my in my reading of it so bacteria and
fungi can create massive communities
which suddenly take on a ultra
intelligence that's far beyond the
capacity of any individual within the
community
and so in in the fungal world we can see
chemical responses to a nutrient load
for example so if you you've deposit a
bunch of fertilizer on one corner of a
farm the entire mycelial colony starts
to sense an imbalance in the ecosystem
across many acres and you go and biopsy
the soil on the other side of the farm a
few weeks later and you find that the
nutrients you just dumped in here have
suddenly appeared over here and so
there's a intelligent distribution of
resources through very complicated very
distant you know systems and so that's
one way in which we watch quorum sensing
happen but a bigger one can be seen as
we kind of keep moving up the biologic
chain and a good example is trees and so
if you let cattle into a new paddock
that they've never been in they all go
for the trees first we think of them as
as as grass eaters but they always shoot
for the trees first and so they'll go
for the trees and though of the lower
leaves off the trees and suddenly the
trees were sensing the the damage being
done we'll wait for a period of time
until it reaches a point where I
realized that that's there gonna be a
detriment of detrimental effect which
interesting that there's a rate of loss
that's not judged for mammals probably
good for it so the tree is getting
pruned by the cow and it recognizes that
as being beneficial to encourage more
crown growth and more growth up top and
then it suddenly senses okay that's
enough and it puts out a chemical to
make the leaves bitter and the cows will
immediately stop eating the rest of the
leaves so they then move on to the grass
the giraffes do this in an african tree
systems as well and so the giraffes
willkommen in a new space and start
eating and they'll eat an entire tree
and less and of course there's they're
sensing happening and the tree suddenly
exerts this this new chemical shift and
it gets bitter and that but
interestingly they've now recognized
that an entire grove of trees will sense
that one trees responds and the entire
grove will go bitter simultaneously
and so there's intelligent communication
happening between trees that cover you
know large you know square mile kind of
spaces and so there's this hyper
intelligence that happens when organisms
start to cooperatively recognize
themselves of being able to achieve a
bigger network of sensing communication
and ultimately processing and
information processing and therefore
intelligence and we see this repeated in
nature everywhere we look from the hive
mind and the way that these you know
colonize and operate from the migration
of birds and and we kind of tend to look
at it and say wow wouldn't it be cool if
like humans could communicate like that
like the Borg in Star Trek yeah and
that's the dark version of that I
suppose but but but you know to what
extent is is the human organism able to
communicate in a more networked fashion
like this yeah so before I get to human
human actually it just came to me that
there's something maybe even helped me
create this action that before two
together
I had a moment and when I was snorkeling
off the coast of Tulum Mexico many years
ago now but I was in this was in my
alone face I had decided as gonna become
a monk and so my first couple
conversations with with Jenn was how I
was a monk and I was never gonna being
another relationship and all this and so
she apparently saw through all of that
[ __ ] story that I was creating for
myself and this is cubicle himself had a
new identity of I'm a monk and and so
but I was in my monk mode and as um
feeling disconnected and wanting connect
in my life and where I often feel most
connected is floating in the ocean alone
over coral reef and and just watching
this civilization below me that I I
don't really feel any belonging to but I
just watch it and all of its beautiful
connectivity and I'm fascinated by the
tiniest things in coral reefs
like the big fish are cool but I'm just
fascinated by little hairlike structures
that wave back and forth and what the
hell are those doing and like whoa yeah
those things are finding purpose and
just being a hair that waves back and
forth all day in the ocean it just goes
back and forth and back and forth back
and forth back and forth and that that
little hairlike thing on the coral reef
has never woken up with us an identity
crisis yeah it's like no this is what I
do man I'm in flow I'm like I got the
ocean and it's the waves and I can sense
what's going on in the other side of the
ocean because there's ripples that
happen through and can sense that and
connected I'm like I'm the sensory
system for the entire planet that's 70%
water
oh my god how beautiful is that to be a
sensory fibre for the ocean itself and
to know what's happening on the planet
and I am coral reef and you get in that
state it's like okay this is this is
freakin beautiful you start to get
yourself in there and so I decided you
know there was a day where I didn't have
time to get to go travel to one of the
reach that I always loved traveling to
but I just wanted to get out the waters
I just like started swimming out with my
snorkel and just going out just there
was no expectation of reef because it
was just an all sand and it was out
there and swam and swam swimming and
then I started find you know not really
reef per se but chunks a coral and
chunks of you know some amazing you know
those fern corals that are out there and
stuff like that and so sound some cool
things and I was like that's nice and I
popped my head back looked out and
realized I was way further away from the
shore than I had ever really been and I
got you know a little panic because I'm
not like super swimmer dude or anything
like that and just had that little
moment of like oh my god I hope I can
get back like I had so long ways and and
so I started back and I'm swimming back
and you know quickly got over that
little panic attack and it was like okay
I just just keep at it and got my head
back down in the water and just cruising
and suddenly I got surrounded by a
massive school of sardines and this went
on for 45 minutes that I was in this
swarm of sardines and it's more life
than you can even really begin to
describe I mean this thing must have
been a quarter mile in length at least
you know this this massive school of
fish
and interests them as soon as I I saw it
coming and I didn't you know at first
know what it was it looked like a ship
or something like that like it looked
like a big solid structure coming to me
and look above the water there's nothing
there and it's coming at me so fast it
wasn't like I'm gonna run away from this
thing is like I'm gonna get hit by this
thing and we're by the time they were
about ten feet away I could start to
pick out that they were all these
cylinders that was a silver heads of all
these fish and then they swarm came
around me and they respected my field -
I'd say probably almost exactly six
inches like they were just completely
around me and I was completely engulfed
and had very quickly lost orientation
whereas you lose sense of up and down
because there's no sunlight you're just
in silver just flashing silver up down
all around and I got so excited I was
like they can see me and I could push my
hand as fast as I quit out in the water
and I couldn't touch a fish you know and
there's like a go that and maybe six
inches all the way around my arm and it
looked and I'd pull my arm back and I
couldn't even see a hole like they would
close in on that space so fast that my I
couldn't sense the speed and so they
were this ultimate quorum right there
this ultimate organism made of probably
hundreds of millions of fish they're all
like a few inches long and they covered
in young and so they're moving past me
pretty quickly over this 45 minute
period and then you know as for my thing
and some minutes into this I start to
get really panicked because I'm I think
that I'm starting to become sardine
I'm starting to have so much sardine
energy around me that I'm like it's a it
was exciting for those first few minutes
it was like this is I'm having a
once-in-a-lifetime moment and you know
you all have had those moments really
like this will never happen to me again
I'm probably the only human experiences
right now on this planet and you're
nearing that elated says and then pretty
soon you're like you know I I don't know
what life is gonna be after this moment
like nothing's the same after this
moment and I would say that many of you
this week are in a sardine moment
of your starting in a sense an energy
field there is an organism that you're
starting to plug into you that you've
always been craving but your feeling of
fear of loss of a identity because
nothing's gonna be the same when you go
back if it is you missed a big
opportunity you need to become sardine
here okay you need to become Buffalo
here as you have did anybody pick the
sardine card yeah
and so sardine was such an interesting
experience and one of the I didn't even
realize this but this is freaking
profound it comes right back to where we
started which is about you know some
minutes into this experience I had
become sardine I had become relaxed into
that that okay I'm probably still gonna
be human on the other side of this I
will be changed but I'm not actually
sardine yet and so I got past that panic
attack and then suddenly there's these
explosions of bubbles around me just
massive explore bubble explosions and I
couldn't figure out what it was for some
time and then I happened to have a
little clearing in the fish long enough
for me to see Pelican feet on the water
surface around me and realized that the
pelicans were bursting in but their trip
there traversed through the water and
then back up with a fish in her mouth
was so fast that my I wasn't quick
enough in that ten thousandth of a
second to see it your eye can perceive
at about that ten thousandth of a second
rate and so by the time I was sensing
something all I could see was bubbles
and so I couldn't track their trajectory
through the water because it was beyond
that and that speed at which my eyes are
capable of capturing neurologically what
I was seeing and as soon as I saw the
pelican feet and a split second I
figured out what's going on I feel this
immediate emotional reaction of my
friends were getting eaten like this is
terrible that we're having loss and I
say and and I went there for just a
split second and sardine said back to me
like somebody screaming at me no like
wrong and I tied back into that energy
in there had been
and the Latian event in this group of
fish they were elated in this moment of
pelicans hitting and there was this rise
in energy happening in this thing as
transformation was happening at a very
very high energetic level and so they
there was zero empathy for the loss of
their brethren and you see that same
thing when 1 million men marched in the
war there's a loss of empathy for the
individual and there's only a sense of
there's human suffering and there's
human victory and I want to be a part of
that and I'm just as willing to be part
of the human suffering and loss of life
as I am to be part of the victory and
that is just the blind and so I think in
warfare we can reach the state of non
empathic presence and so our challenge
now as humans is I believe to reach non
and Pathak presence without war what if
we can non empathically witness loss of
life you mentioned how can we possibly
not treat with and with opiates and
somebody who's suffering at the end of
life because we feel for them well
that's where we [ __ ] things up I think
is we start having all these emotional
responses to this situation which
inevitably is selfish because your
emotions have nothing to do with that
person's journey and you're putting your
journey on that person's thing
projecting all your crap on that
situation of somebody who's in a train
and what is that going to do to their
energy field it's going to drop their
energy and they're gonna suffer more for
it and so my nurses on the hospice
environment did the best thing in the
world which was touch patients and the
most powerful ones used Reiki which is
an age-old technique for not touching
them just with skin but touching them
with energy and put raising their
vibration and pain goes down immediately
immediately and so a non empathic
approach to pain and loss of life raises
vibration these fish demonstrated this
in an incredible way of they realized
that there was a cycle of life happening
right now and they wanted to be a
and they were not afraid of that cycle
of life they were they in fact were
excited they were thrilled by the
opportunity to be engaged in the cycle
of life which was death and rebirth that
same story takes me to have thought of
viktor schauberger if you haven't heard
viktor schauberger you got to look this
guy up one of the greatest minds of 20th
century and probably one of the most
under all the geniuses of that century
he he was a forester and that's why he
didn't get much attention austrian
forest or fifth-generation austrian
forests are in the same force so imagine
the intelligence that would come into a
human being that for five generations
his dad grandfather grandfather
grandfather grandfather had been
observing the same section of Austrian
Highland forests what intelligence would
come from that kind of quorum sensing
multi-generational intelligence and when
you read viktor schauberger you see what
comes out of that this man as a forester
had more profound discoveries of human
biology than any physician or scientist
in that century he discovered that the
heart is not a pump for blood he
discovered that how fish can sit dead
still in a fast running river and not
move not be swept downstream have you
guys seen that before isn't that the
weirdest thing have you even asked
yourself why is that happening the fast
running stream and the fish is dead
still not moving
no effort to it but he's not being swept
into the current and he figured out that
the shape of the fish scales are
designed in those river fish to create
an a sweep of energy across the scale
that creates a negative charge on the
backside of that scale that pulls the
fish forward and so the fish is creating
a magnet that is equal exactly to the
speed of the water and so if the water
flows faster it pulls forward faster if
it slows down it pulls slows down at the
exact rate such that it doesn't move and
it doesn't need to move a fin
to stay in exactly the same velocity as
the water that's traveling by it
that guy figured that [ __ ] out without
any devices with anything he figured it
out staring at nature and observing
nature at this exquisite level and one
of the observations he made that ties
back to the sardines and where I would
love for you and I to get to as human
beings as he had long witnessed and
wrote about even this phenomenon that in
these high mountain lakes of austria he
would see an eagle circling a lake and
it would go into a tighter and tighter
circle in that lake and pull and then he
would see a fish following the shadow of
the eagle and the eagle would pull it
into a tighter and tighter vortex and
then right at the center of the lake
would grab the fish and take off and so
he had this whole amazing theory that he
observed of how Eagles go fishing and
they create a vortex of energy and pull
a fish into the vortex and and then some
years later he happened to look down he
was high enough and that just the right
trajectory where he saw a fish swimming
in a giant circle around the outside of
a lake he's like that's weird so he sat
down and sure enough kept seeing come by
and laughs and did this for about thirty
minutes before an eagle came and started
following the fish and got tighter and
tighter tighter and tighter and he said
I've seen this dance before and he
realized this time that in the last
couple split seconds the Eagle never
reached inside the water the fish jumped
out of the water into the talons of the
eagle so he realized all those years he
was not observing Eagles fishing he was
observing fish jumping to a different
plane that's so interesting to me what
if we saw death as a heightening of our
experience an opportunity to go four
dimensional release ourselves of these
3d environments can you imagine the fish
that was limited to that lake for its
entire existence and then got to soar
into the sky
for a few seconds to witness what the
mountains look like see down at that
Lake that it had spent its entire life
with and be like oh my god that was the
freakin box I've been stuck in how's it
a little speck of water down there and
these grandiose mountains and oh my god
there's lakes all over the place I
didn't realize oh my gosh look at the
freakin expanses of life around me and
that's exactly what my patients come
back from the dead with why the hell did
you pull me back here
you brought me right back into the box
and I am in pain and you've stuck a
latex tube in every orifice of my body
and I don't want to be here and you keep
touching me with those goddamn latex
gloves I just want to be connected back
to universe and connected at a high
level to nature you're yearning for that
and you'll get there and we're we're
running a pretty good rate of pretty
damn near 100% death for humankind
and so you can get to that expansion and
we're cruising there now as a species
you know Jemma talked so well yesterday
about you know this this you know speed
of the loss of life that we're now in I
wasn't she wasn't seen beautiful
yesterday I just so blessed to listen to
you yesterday there there's such hope in
somebody finding truth in their life and
being willing to blow up their paradigm
you're the only freaking crazy doctor
and all of that freaking crazy Island of
the UK willing to be as crazy as you are
that's ridiculous and brave and
interesting and you're breaking apart
cubicles that people have put you in and
you're breaking apart in education that
built a box for you to be in and you're
blowing that apart and I think that's
what makes your whole podcast compelling
is you interview people that have had to
through often real hardship blow up
their paradigm and blow up that cubicle
to find themselves larger than what they
thought they were before but there's so
much beauty in that destruction right
and I and I think it does it does relate
to these stories that you're talking
about
with the fish and the ego on the
sardines in the sense that we there you
know maybe we need to blow up this
paradigm or that we've constructed
around you know empathy for suffering
and the life and death cycle right so
it's like from you through your lens and
these stories that you've just told the
most empathetic thing that we can
actually do is to suspend our empathy
and the rationale behind that is to
broaden the aperture through which we
perceive life and death and suffering
and growth you know one of the things
that Julie talks about a lot is is not
depriving people of their divine moment
like this this empathy that we have for
pain and you know suffering at the end
of and of life can easily be applied to
how we approach people in their various
suffering moments throughout life to
suspend empathy is also to respect and
empower the person who's going through
whatever they're going through so that
they can fully embrace what's being
presented to them so that they have the
facility to undergo that transformation
for themselves to blow up their own
paradigm about who they are so that they
can get to that next place it's hugely
important and I guarantee you that each
of you who are in a relationship right
now are in some ways palliating your
partner and you're you're trying to
salve their pain and therefore keeping
them from transformation and we do this
out of altruism but it's a it's a broken
model of altruism misguided altruism and
so we we show what we think is
compassion to one another which in the
end is selfishness because we're
exercising our moment to redefine our
self-identity as a compassionate person
or as a giver or as a server and also I
mean we're selfishly using that person's
pain to buoy up our self identity which
is vampiric really it's completely
vampiric and you will come to feel this
in your life when you get good at
recognising these patterns of your own
behavior you'll suddenly realize that
people are literally vampires on your
energy and they're sucking life out of
you and you created those you literally
like walked up to the vampires like you
wanted to suck on this you know it's
just like here's my carotid yeah just
take the radial artery it's right here
you know oh you too I got another one no
problem I've got it here you could suck
up my ankle
you're you are draining yourself
intentionally to maintain some belief
system about why you're valuable you
know don't don't
empathically approach the people around
you to support your sense of identity
it's it's the most awful thing that we
could do to each other is to leech on to
a moment of pain and suffering so that
we can feel better about ourselves and
so you need to stop being so abusive to
one another in your self professed care
for one another we were talking before
the podcast and you were telling me
about this study among college students
solving this puzzle and and how that
kind of applies to yeah this super
consciousness that we have can you just
share that so I think that you probably
felt that though but in the description
of the sardines for example did you or
the coral reef did you have a moment
where you felt that extension of
intelligence like you suddenly feel like
oh yeah I could literally stick my toe
in the ocean and if i sat there long
enough I could sense everything that's
going on on the planet you know there's
that level of connectivity and so quorum
sensing as we started with there is that
philosophy that in the end everything is
electrons and everything's electrons
interacting with protons and so this is
accounts for about point zero zero zero
one percent of the space that we live in
and so we are 99.999 7% vacuum space and
so is everything the planet the
microbiome everything is vacuum space
and so we have almost nothing solid but
what is solid is these little protons
that haven't recently been recognized to
have the same structure as the black
hole that's in the middle of our galaxy
and so these black holes are these
massive energetic centers of gravity
that pull in everything including light
energy and kick stuff back out and so
Steven Hawkins became known for many
great discoveries but one of them was
the Hawkins particles again named after
him and he recognized that black holes
out in our space are putting out all
these particles of information in this
digital data that's just flowing out of
black holes and he yelled for a long
time that that was just chaotic
information and then more recently a lot
of astrophysicists all came to the
agreement that know that structured
information and through other work in
astrophysics they've realized that all
the black holes were connected through
wormholes and the like and so black
holes holes are all connected there's a
black hole at the center for pretty much
every galaxy out there and so we have
billions of galaxies throughout the
universe and so we have the billions of
black holes they're all connected and
that's all fascinating and when you
start to think about what would be the
structured data coming out of black
holes throughout the universe does that
start to resemble what we might call the
intention of God or the information of a
super computer there is a super
intelligence that is a process through
all of the black holes in the universe
and so there's a stream of information
of data structured coming out of all the
black holes and flowing into the entire
universe and from that we see the
organization of plasma and matter and
planets and solar systems and galaxies
and dolts my organisms on those planets
and then humans and then we rush down
into the cells within your hand and then
you look down into your hand you realize
okay that's all the Tomic structure and
you zip down deeper and it's like yep
this is all all made out of these little
tiny protons ultimately and so then the
same Haramain who's an incredible
physicist right now if you haven't seen
his stuff you need to look up in the
seam and assi am haramain and i think
it's a gr r i'm gonna butcher that last
name am II I n Haramain and the seams
work is showing that the proton is a
tiny tiny black hole and functions with
all of the physical features of a black
hole and what's rushing in and out of
the black holes is electrons and the
electrons are speeding across
environments and exchanging information
and what how this manifests then is
exchange of information at the atomic
level and at the atomic level of these
atoms exchanging insider protons which
are basically the central processing
units of these of a computer and so you
got the CPU that's processing all the
information coming out of the electron
electron reacts with its environment and
then it comes back into the proton to
tell the proton what it just experienced
a proton then just kicks out okay just
this is what's my environment and so it
now informs all the other electrons that
come in and okay this is what the
experience is out there and then all the
black holes are communicating what all
the protons in your body which is
billions and billions and billions and
billions and billions are all
communicating and the electrons are
exchanging very quickly and so over this
hour and a half or whatever we've been
in this room together we've all
exchanged almost all of our electrons
very quickly you know all of the atoms
in all of our cells and all of our
molecules exchanging electrons we have
this huge cloud of electrons in here
that have all exchanged and now transit
and transected into the protons and
exchanged information the speed at which
this happens is proved in these
experiments that we were talking about
and so they take groups of 30 or 40
students college students and give them
a really difficult word word puzzle
it's a crossword puzzle and they time
how long it takes for this group of
students to solve this puzzle together
and then as soon as they click the timer
okay 45 minutes whatever it was they
then wait five minutes and then they
start a second group of students across
campus on the same word puzzle and every
time they've done this
the second group finishes a few minutes
faster and so even across the distance
of a campus electrons are exchanged fast
enough that there's a universal
knowingness that's developing in the
environment
and you guys have all witnessed this
overtime hey how many of you have
grandchildren no grandparents in the
room that's mean one grandparent in the
room does anybody have you know kids or
nieces and nephews under the age of five
and so a few more people in the room
what is the reaction of that child to a
small rectangular box that we would call
an iPhone that kid will learn to crawl
just so it can get to the iPhone that
kid will scream bloody murder on an
airplane until mom finally hands over
the iPhone she doesn't want to because
she doesn't want the kid off screen time
doesn't want the kid to be holding a
radiation device but eventually mom
gives in because the kid is fixated on
this freaking little rectangle this is
quorum sensing at the greater level now
is these children are born into an
environment where information technology
is in such a high level of experience in
the human consciousness right now that
the child knows that that's what it must
want more than anything else because
their parents are spending more time on
that little box than anything else it
more than any relationship in their
lives they will spend more time on that
box in a day than they will talk to
their own spouse they will spend more
time on that box than they will interact
for their boss it must be the most
important thing our children can sense
that and so they don't know why it's the
most important thing one year-old has no
idea what the Freak the box is all they
know is very important and they have a
facility in that technology that after
decades of using those damn things
I can't match a three-year-old is way
better on an iPhone than I am because
there's this constant electrical
exchange of information and experience
and so we should take massive pause and
asked what is the quorum sensing right
now through my contribution what is your
daily experience contributing to this
higher electrical state of humanity
are you touching anybody in a day can we
do ourselves a favor right now and can
we just hold hold hands just for the
next however long this is hold dance
that just me and you which will look
awkward but isn't it interesting that we
don't even do this very often right like
it's like the freakin simplest thing in
the world like hey I've got a hand
getting this opposing thumb it's kind of
cool us in the monkeys
and we just fix [ __ ] instead of touch
each other we just fix stuff you guys
are all doing maintenance all day long
and you're not touching another hand
this is the best pain control not only
that we go out of our way to avoid this
this is very awkward and vulnerable yeah
and frightening yeah we both got the
black thing too I noticed that when we
sat down like we must look kind of dorky
up here but got the men in black thing
going on up here and now we're holding
hands and and that you know on some
level you think this is kind of awkward
but again it feels really good like your
hand feels really nice right it's not
sweating yet it might start sweating
it's really lovely because that you have
a softness to the palm that's like kind
of hugging on the collar yes what are
you doing after this yeah I'm free my
wife left this morning Julie just gave
permissions like yeah I feel like you
got the Hall Pass we're good
you guys are touching somebody next to
you and in that touch you're exchanging
an amazing amount of information that's
invisible and you can't see it and you
don't know it yet you don't even know
what you're absorbing from that person
next to you yet and I'm really glad I'm
some touching riches here because he's
talked to a lot of really smart people
over the last and decade and so I'm
going to absorb all kinds of brilliance
out of this hand s's closed her eyes for
a second so we can more immerse
ourselves in that feeling of that
person's hand
just a little pulse of love and out both
hands now just a little pulse now if you
get too dramatic about it
control yourself mm-hmm little pulse and
now do something far more difficult that
I don't even know if I know how to do
yet which is open up your heart right
now and be willing to absorb all the
other love you have so many blocks right
there and walking around so protected
such a well-constructed cubicle around
your heart you're afraid you're
unlovable so just take it down take down
the cubicle walls I don't think
anybody's really opened up their heart
yet cuz nobody's really exhaling huge
right now so let's just try to take a
deep breath in let it all the way out
just look back to your chest and now
turn your attention back to your palms
and just gently ask for love I just want
some love and let it run up your arms
I'm gonna start to fill your chest
I'm just taking another deep breath
together and sucking all that love
and you can't in this moment experience
everything that everybody else in this
room is experienced all the knowledge
they've collected all of the
intelligence that they are capable of
all of the service they've given to
their loved ones it turns out they're
all just as good as you are at pouring
love out and they're just as bad as you
are at taking love in and so the sheer
amount of available love in this room is
infinite there's so much unabsorbed love
in here and I think that's why we are
suffering so much as humanity is we've
disconnected from the vortex the matrix
of love that is literally emanating out
of all of us all the time and we can't
even figure out how to plug back in you
are so loved
I want you to go back in time right now
to the womb here we are right now we're
at some age and we're going to start
traveling back swiftly and go through
your mind's eye whatever hit age twenty
and it's great to be 20 that's such a
cool now you're ten you haven't had to
go through the [ __ ] fuel pretty [ __ ]
yet and you're just like still like in
that wonderful magical moment of being
ten when life's still very simple and
like you just want to go ride bikes with
your friends remember when you're ten
and you catch a perfect Hill on your
bike and you're just flying down at this
complete freedom and no effort
wind whipping by you I remember when you
were five digging your first big hole in
the ground I don't know why we're all
driven to dig holes but we do that all
the time and you were a kid digging a
hole somewhere on a beach or a backyard
and just remember how tiny your hands
are when you're five so funny all hands
are so damn cute and they're funny
almost kind of puffy fat little hands
and then you're like two and you're just
like so pleased with yourself because
you can walk from the coffee table over
to the shelf to rip something off
there's a bookshelf and you're so
pleased with yourself and - and then
suddenly you're there's a newborn and
you're just blowing your mind over the
beauty of the world you just came out of
this like kind of glowy warm space that
was nothing very distinct to see and
you're just in this cacophony of color
sound voices you're just taking all that
in and a brain that has no idea what
it's seen yet but deeper down and that
newborn is a very knowing soul and if we
back up into the womb now where you're
just in embryo not even fully formed yet
I think there's still at some point in
that transition between single-cell and
newborn baby you're animated by this
energy field and this energy field has a
deep knowingness and it has been in the
universe at the beginning of whatever
creation was and you're in the womb with
this deep knowingness inside yourself
and you're the collision of a little bit
of DNA from mom and dad that helps give
structure to the interaction with an
electromagnetic field that will then
manifest a personality that can't be
coded for in the genes it's easy to feel
like it was an amazing parent when you
have one child but when you have a
second child you so they realize you
have nothing to do with this process
they're so different it is like so
impossible different from that first
child and you're like what because
you're not actually from your parents I
would like you all to dwell on that for
a very long moment right now you are not
from your parents so stop blaming them
they didn't create you are you kidding
no they're just lost confused human
beings you came from something much
bigger got much deeper knowingness and
much deeper wisdom to sit in that for a
moment
you're not from your parents that's
wonderful so we have to stop blaming
them for their shortcomings or their
successes we can we can either give them
credit nor nor ridicule for whatever
happened in the parenting journey and
the dominant emotion that I find
underlying most the disease I take care
of his abandonment at some point you had
a moment where you felt abandoned and it
can seem really trivial and it was
really trivial like your parents went
out on a date and for you woke up from a
nap you didn't know they were gonna be
gone and they were gone and you felt
suddenly terrified and lonely like your
parents abandoned you and turns out that
the babysitter was just late and they
showed up and I hear those little things
all the time in fact that's what
engendered the first moment of you
thought you were abandoned and sometimes
it's awful horrific things awful abuses
and all kinds of things that made you
feel abandoned but I want you to realize
in the same way that you are not from
your parents there's no way they could
have abandoned you nor could they give
you any actual companionship on a
spiritual level they are no more
connected with their soul than anybody
else and so they were no more capable of
really being present with you they were
they're biologically for you but they
didn't know how to connect with you at
that spiritual level and my big victory
of my last decade it was really finding
out that when my mom was pretty sick
when I had grown up she had just we're
epilepsy and it was always having
seizures and sizing this caretaking mode
early on in my life and oldest child of
four kids it's kind of taking care of my
siblings while she's having a seizure
taking care of her and I remember being
a grocery store with her head on my lap
and she's having a seizure and people
are freaking out around me and just
patiently waiting for her stop having a
seizure those kinds of experiences I
ended up holding
sent me that I wasn't being nurtured I
wasn't being cared for
I was lonely because my mom couldn't be
there to take care of me and I found out
a few years ago doing some just deep
work with myofascial therapist releasing
grief and the sense of I wasn't nurtured
to find out the embarrassing and
humbling an incredible reality that
there had been angels all over me in
every one of those moments at the soul
level nurturing my soul never letting go
of me and that changed my whole
perception of my story my story had been
a kid with a sick mom had to take care
of people and that moment I realized I'm
a soul that's ancient that's been
nurtured at the highest level of
vibration since before I came into this
body and especially while I've been in
this body so give up your story your
story is not one of hardship I guarantee
it
our forefathers generations had some
hardship that we have never known but
deeper than that there is no hardship on
the soul level because the souls move as
a sardine would those souls that solely
within you as literally as as non
empathetic and non empathic as the fish
it's just seeking a higher vibration and
it's asking you to a higher vibration
and so you are an ancient soul wrapped
up in this moment you are not abandoned
at any moment you have been cared for on
a level that defies our understanding
our words the word angel is not
sufficient these are beings light these
are beings of energy that we have fairly
no card struck to understand in our
human minds and they're all around us
and we don't even understand that we
don't know why we don't know how to
interact with up entirely
but life is not the way it looks around
you and you're gonna get there faster to
the state of being being willing to let
go of your cubicle
what story have you been telling
everybody that you have got to get don't
run I want you to rebirth right now and
you're in the womb right now and I just
want you to come back into this world
with completely fresh eyes travel down
that birth canal in that dark tunnel and
there's light at the end of that tunnel
there's total chaos at that another tone
for all your perceptive limitations
because you're about to step back into
the world without any of your previous
constructed self-identity and that's
gonna feel like chaos you're not gonna
be able to make immediate sense of
everything because you're gonna keep
checking yourself say is that my old
story be willing to be completely
rebirth and we need to do that every
single day because you're so patterned
and creating a new story and you're just
gonna go build another one and you're
gonna fashion a new cubicle and you're
gonna be very super pleased with it
you think it's all shiny and cool and
you'll be just as stuck as you were
before and so what will the core of the
manifest
what are we going to do with our time so
that we set in motion electrons that
would inform not just our fellow man but
the children that would come after us
what are the whales get a sense right
now can we connect with those fish and
whales in the sea right now and say I'm
sorry I am so sorry for all the plastic
in your belly I am so sorry for our
selfish dominance this planet
thank you for your grace and your
willingness to connect instantaneously
with us thank you for welcoming us in a
sardine and a buffalo and Wolf Eagle
fish egg whatever card you pulled this
week I want you go to that space for a
moment go to your egg for a moment go to
your card and think about that what were
you called to become this week have you
let go enough of your story that you can
become that thing oh I see Zach thank
you for that beautiful offering
how's everybody feel
reborn appreciate you my friend thank
you thank you for being here with all of
us so gratefully to you so ridiculous
that you showed up seven billion people
on the planet you guys showed up seven
billion this is the cream of the frickin
crop right here seven billion rows right
now this week to become something bigger
than yourself tap into something deeper
and I love it that you guys pull this
trick on everybody yeah okay guys this
vegan thing and we got some good food
and we run yeah [ __ ] you guys are
like a freakin wrecking ball of previous
lifetimes and I freaking love this place
thank you for the sneak attacks thank
you for the well-designed trust and
that's actually what you've created in
your podcasts and we've come to trust
you in the language and the information
you share with us we've come to trust
these layers of Education you guys put
out in the world and that trust allowed
us to come to this place where we could
be in deep relationship without having
even known each other before since
you're a friend of rich and Julie you're
my friend too
and that started us off on a really
strong point and we've built some really
cool friendships that privacy you can
hear all the exchanges like there's a
lot people for you you're really living
in is your keep touching each other
you're gonna go back into an environment
like at home where everybody thinks they
know who you are because you only very
carefully tribes rise very to the
cubicle of consciousness as I do
everybody and I think that we can
actually get to a sardine moment without
that catastrophic death and
disappearance of our species that were
cruising towards and so we got about
thirty years to figure it out if we
don't figure out in 30 years we will see
the highest level of suffering
ever measured in human history as we
collapse to our endpoint and if that's
our path let's hold on to this moment
too for that is that we need to be non
empathic non emotional about the the
demise of our species as well and we
need to know that at that point we're
just one giant fish jumping into the
towns of a bigger eagle that we can't
see yet and so we don't need to be
overly dramatic about the end of our
species or this the sixth extinction
it's okay
it's our path mother earth and saw it
coming and she's recovered from from
massive extinctions before and life just
explodes right back and so we should be
in no question of of the good stuff on
the other side but if in the next thirty
years you guys start really being
vulnerable enough to your whole
communities and really seeking more
hand-holding in your life we're gonna
freakin create a new society and I'm
very excited to bring more stuff to you
guys too for what my tribe is doing back
in the States and around the world now
we have a whole team of thinkers that
are gonna keep bringing stuff to you
guys so rich lying I think we're gonna
have an opportunity to roll out one of
the biggest stories of human history in
these next couple months as we we start
to tell a story about the rise and fall
of Empire and we said we're going to
tell a story about what are the patterns
of human behavior that need to be
destructed because not only have each of
us constructed a story our societies and
our empires have constructed a story
that is keeping us from our fullest
capacity to become one and to become one
species that would be a quorum and would
act at an extremely high intelligence
level that's literally never been
witnessed before and we will connect to
alien species and we will connect all
kinds of things in this universe
physical and non-physical through an
actual quorum event when seven billion
people become one and are willing to
share everything
most of all love and whatever that is
and so I'm honored to be among you can't
wait for the next chapters to unfold
boom right that guy just never
disappoints so cool such a blessing to
be able to share his powerful message
with all you guys here today hope you
guys enjoyed it for even more on dr.
Bush check the show notes on the episode
page at rich WorldCom go to his website
Zack Bush MD comm and I would also
suggest visiting farmers footprint us
where you can watch the first
installment of his docu-series and learn
more about the farmers footprint mission
and should you be so moved
contribute to the cause again I want to
thank everyone who attended our retreat
in Italy for collectively raising 81
thousand dollars for that project you
guys are amazing
and finally let Zack know how this one
landed for you by sharing your thoughts
with him directly on twitter at dr. Zack
Bush or on instagram at Zack Bush MD if
you want to support the work we do here
on the podcast just tell your friends
about your favorite episode or about the
show in general share what you're
listening to on social media take a
screen grab tag me I like to retweet
that stuff or share it on Instagram
subscribe to the show on Apple podcast
Spotify YouTube Google podcasts wherever
you listen to this or watch it leave a
review on Apple podcast and you can
support our work on patreon at Rich roll
com forward slash donate great
appreciation to everybody who helped put
on this show today
Jason camiolo for audio engineering
production shownotes interstitial music
my stepson tyler Pyatt who handled the
audio engineering in italy to record
this to capture it
blake curtis and margo Lubin there was
no video this time but hey Blake's with
me today doing audio engineering work so
many thanks to you guys nonetheless
Jessica Miranda for graphics DK for
advertiser relationships Leia murasa
[ __ ] for photographs of this episode in
Italy and theme music is always by
analemma
appreciate you guys I love you without
you guys I'm nothing I will see you back
here next week with a great conversation
with my friend the actor Titus Welliver
he's one of those guys you see him and
you're like that guy this guy's been in
everything you like I don't know if I
know his name but he's that guy you
probably know him from Bosch the TV
series on Amazon he's a great dude we
had a great conversation you're not
gonna want to miss it so stay tuned
until then as dr. bush says pain can be
a great teacher become comfortable with
being uncomfortable peace plants
[Music]